now to new developments in the crisis at
our Southern border the number of
migrants Crossing in El Paso Texas has
actually gone down in recent days but
there are continued fears of a huge
spike in the days ahead because of a
pandemic era immigration policy that
could soon expire could soon expire
perhaps as early as midnight tonight all
that despite a temporary hold on the
rule from the Supreme Court Omar
villafranca has more now from El Paso
which is under a state of emergency
together
the Border has spilled over into El Paso
where thousands of migrants seeking
Asylum are overwhelming shelters have
you ever seen it like this no John
Martin runs an El Paso homeless shelter
that is mostly filled with migrants
capacity is 120 but to avoid the
freezing temperatures earlier this week
more than 230 people packed the rooms
and hallways we're simply running out of
food many of the migrants are from
Nicaragua or Venezuela like Miliani and
her two-year-old son Mila they've slept
in the shelter for the past three days
what do you want to do here
do you worry that this city in this
County will reach a Breaking Point well
I don't know there's such a thing as a
breaking point because you have no
choice judge Ricardo Samaniego is the
top elected official in El Paso County
he says El pasoans are doing their best
to feed clothe and bust hundreds of
migrants every day to cities like
Phoenix San San Antonio and New York
like 32 year old Yasmine Hernandez and
her seven-month-old son Liam from
Guatemala
Denver they're heading to Denver once
she gets enough money for a bus ticket
she wants to find an office job in
Colorado and save enough money to bring
the rest of her family to the U.S
the White House is asking for billions
of dollars to help move migrants to
additional facilities or remove them if
warranted but El Paso's mayor says
that's a long-term solution for a very
immediate problem at the end of the day
this is strictly a Band-Aid for
something that's bigger than El Paso
because we can continue to go at this
rate
the number of migrants coming to El Paso
has dropped from about 2500 today early
this month to about 1300 on Monday but
still the El Paso mayor is asking for
help from the National Guard and they
are on standby Gail
Omar thank you